and it's true the laws were made so that
african-americans and Latinos would go
to jail and and it was when I was in
prison african-americans and Latinos
were 40% of the prison population wise
for 60 now whites and african-americans
identical and if you add
african-americans and Latinos then you
know what you got 70% of the prison
population why so why were we not
fighting for that why would you not stop
those laws that said we're gonna keep
you safe for [ __ ] you give me saved
by destroying communities you know
locking up kids that are not criminals
yeah yeah they committed an offense
everyone needs to pay but you're right
the bigger I can for 450 million are
still government and get ten years I
didn't say a good thing I got tenure
because of the money I'm not saying that
but the big the big guys all they sit
back there is just tell them people they
know a lot people tell huh
so they can reduce the center we do the
center reduce the sentence and prisoner
full of nobodies 16 17 18 your kids
doing life working the kids gonna become
an animal an animal do we care no we got
private prisons not as corrupt as
anything is and and that's that's how we
change the world you know we change the
world with our votes we change the world
by changing our communities realizing
that listen right now you got all this
corporation giving money to African
American movement and it's great I'm so
glad finally they're doing it but I bet
I would bet how many of them are really
doing it because they feel it deep down
inside but it doesn't matter a lot of
the year it's what matters right yeah
they're buying it further yeah exactly
so roger goodell right now is
apologizing for how did he destroy
Kaepernick's life because the guy all he
did was Neal wasn't jumping on the
bandwagon right yeah he didn't say [ __ ]
well right now exactly right now he'd be
freaking crucified right so they're all
hypocrites mm-hmm you know I love
Michael Jordan right cuz I think he's
probably the greatest athlete ever was
but freak Michael you couldn't give him
that money long time ago why now because
now he's popular we're all standing
together and a lot of major stakes in
prisons - no no no no he's I heard of
the
know if people gamble as much as he does
but yeah but the thing is these guys so
much you know Michael's a good guy man
look like like one guy said if Michael
Jordan Gann was a million dollars it's
like you're nine ten dollars so it's
done you know he's too proud to gamble
his team you know it's just the greatest
athlete man he's just it was
unbelievable I admire him tremendously
but you know when you got all this money
man you can't you gotta look at the guy
left behind you know do like LeBron he
moved into Brentwood Brentwood in in
California's rich mm-hmm
mega rich multi-millionaire houses or
white he LeBron James he's gonna be
receptacle he's LeBron James not that
he's gonna be liked
no no you know but that's the world
that's the world we live in and we have
to be real about the fact that since the
time of Abraham you know we always have
one human being despising another human
being and that's not gonna change no
matter how many cities we burn or
nothing but that shouldn't be our focus
yeah it's good like Van Jones said we're
raising awareness more people talking
about it and hopefully people would have
great people of color will have greater
opportunities but the truth of the
matter is you know how you get the
greater opportunity when you get
educated and when you make them pick you
right you know when I got the high
scholarship at Loyola it wasn't because
I was Hispanic like the other students
said oh he saw formative action no I got
it because I always have perfect score
my G reason 4.0 in my masters and
because I've written five papers and
published them already in a master's
program when none of them had so yeah I
don't believe in luck I think luck is
preparing yourself for the right
opportunity at the right time if someone
said right now George I'm gonna give you
air force one all you gotta do is fly it
to Camp David man what an unlucky guy
cuz I can fly Air Force One but if they
tell me to fly you know a high
performance Meridian I can't because I
have a pilot's license so oh I'm lucky
no no there's no luck you know luck is
now you position yourself like a ben
Carson man no father
you know the guy becomes one of the most
renowned surgeons in America did he get
the job that he get that he get to
separate those twins because it was
black no cuz he was the brightest
african-american did Obama get electical
he was black knuckle he was brilliant
right you know did he get the first
african-american head of the Harvard
review because he was back no now we we
have to fight twice as hard as others
I'll tell you that much to be in the
same category but so what
fight you know show the world what you
got
you earned it and and the sad part is
that we are leaving a whole community of
kids behind they have no chance no
chance man I see them coming to Paris to
cry you realize that 70% of all this
african-american kids coming to prison
can't even read or write and so what I
did I created a program in the Education
Department to teach them to get a GED -
so at least they'd have a high school
diploma you should see how proud you see
how hard they work for it
why because somebody believed in them
that's all kids need man all kids need
Abraham Lincoln said a child will be
your next president in Ex Baxter you
next lawyer your next congressman the
fate of humanity lies in the hands of
our children think about those were the
fate of humanity look at where humanity
is going right now because we're not
educating our kids Latin America perfect
example horrific education program you
know why because the Dumber you keep the
people the more controllable they are
you can't control an educated person
so let's rebuild our communities yeah
let's fight prison reform let's fight
social justice reform you know and say
enough is enough and then we start to
begin to change the world and before we
do your own changers that watch CNN and
Fox know people yeah you know one adores
the present one hates the present no
look yeah I don't like everything he
doesn't relate to something that he does
because you know you got to be impartial
I just can't hate the guy because oh I'm
a Democrat I just can't pray there's
nothing right and whatever you're doing
is all wrong right oh you don't and idea
of the date the bottom line is you don't
like him vote him out
but why why he's involved pray for him
because his success is yours I don't
know if you figured that out or not yeah
so you know and it's we all do some
wrong but hey I wouldn't want to be
President no I don't know I don't know
no I don't know who would especially him
he had the he had the life before he
decided to become president yeah I mean
he would love all the people hate him
loved him
yeah right I mean I love the mango they
got would go Howard Stern he would be
cool yeah say crazy stuff you know I
didn't like his position as Hispanics
and that threw me off but you know no
one's perfect
I am by no means man my wife was to just
look at me for my faults we won't be
married 25 years well that's amazing man
you have your message and your story is
extremely powerful and thank you so much
for coming on here and sharing it with
everybody let everybody know where they
can find your book and where they can
find you online your website your social
media yeah if they go to my web page
Jorge Valdez jo rge Valdez PhD comm
Valdez with an S and you sign on to our
community they'll get a free copy of my
book my latest book you can go to my
youtube channel and subscribe everything
we try to do is to make a difference the
books that we sell none of the money
comes to me or what you did no it goes
to to send it to a prisoner so they
would find a different turn ative to
life and at least if nothing else find
hope in a hopeless situation so we have
a YouTube channel we have a podcast I
just came up with a journal which i
think is my greatest work I mean I spent
half of my life doing my PhD
dissertation three people read it and
call narco mindset journal and you can
go to knock on mindset calm and what it
is is in my son my 16 year old son asked
about he was 16 when he was really
messed up with drugs he asked me to
about a year ago said dad he's super
successful now his way to become a
millionaire married little daughter his
own home people can't believe that he
was addicted to drugs when he was young
not addicted but he was messed up with
drugs anyway came to live with me said
dad why don't you write a journal that
people can look at the principal you've
given me through
life integrity and into action so every
week it's a 12-week so I I pick a
subject or the things are most important
and I end up with a code at the end so I
said like win-win for you like proactive
I said why I never lost a gram of
cocaine never lost a load why because I
was so anal about an obsessive about
being proactive mm-hmm I looked at every
little detail that could go wrong from
the engine to the mechanic I never had a
pilot from the earth days go by himself
because why well what if there was an
operation going where else would heal
and I would bring a Colombian pilot why
did they were follow him here and he
could tell him where he was going so I
was always very meticulous so I talk
about that because America is the most
reactive so sign in the world right we
know not about how many thank you here I
never thought my child commit suicide
really well maybe you just never looked
and so I wrote I write those those items
and then you apply I apply them to your
family your work and in your personal
and how in twelve weeks you've changed
your mindset where he says the mindset
that I had to overcome tortures to
overcome ten years in jail to lose
everything I have to build a
multi-million dollar drug empire and
then to build a multi-million dollar
company so I just finished writing that
and I'm really happy about that because
it's you know how people change their
mindset while I look at this virus as a
joke why am I not worried about none of
it well I take the precautions right I
wash my hands you know when do you work
but at the other day if I live I live
for Jesus if I die go with Jesus so you
know I thought would be there by 27 hey
you your days are marks I'm not worried
I'm gonna live life I live life as if
today's my last day every day I do the
best I can every day I love my kids I
invest in my kids lives you know and and
that's the mindset so we're living in
fear you know I live with love
[Laughter]